welcome to another thankful Thursday I
believe it's important to thank the
people who've had an impact on your life
on your business you can't do this alone
there are people out there helping you
and I believe that you got to take the
opportunity to say thank you today I
want to thank Mark Allah hang a mark is
my real estate agent he helped me sell
my office he helped me move into my
condo here now how did I find mark i
also want to mark because you his office
was right next to mine so wasn't a
referral I didn't know a real estate
agent that I liked and trusted and he
was the closest one so is that ok let's
give him a shot and see what happens and
when I was moving into my condo this is
a rental so don't actually own this
place you know real estate agents don't
make a lot of money off of a rental
right that it's not the business they
want to be and it's not their game and a
lot of agents don't want to work with
you because they don't deseo I don't do
apartment rentals I just do housing
purchase and sale and Mark you know
didn't give me any attitude at all with
super helpful super kind took me around
all the places and what really stood out
was this so he helped me get my place
help me negotiate a deal that was all
great and stuff that you know you'd
expect an agent to do I expect that a
decent agent to do fine what made the
difference though is on my first week
here my fridge started leaking water
there's water all over the floor it's
kind of the fridge I don't know what's
wrong i'm not a handy person and so I
call up markets hey Mark dude like i
love the condo but this is this isn't
great how do i fix my fridge should i
contact the landlord try to contact the
building manager and he said you know
what this is something that the landlord
really should take care of but for these
little kinds of things you don't want to
be bugging the landlord all the time
she'd try to take care of her yourself
you get it done a lot faster and i said
well that's great mark but then i have
zero technical skills okay handyman
level is is below zero i could change a
light bulb but that's about it you know
asking into a video ask you to help
entrepreneurs i'm all in but fixing
stuff around the place no i can't do it
and so he said you know what are you
home tomorrow night and i said i was i'm
gonna come over and check it out for you
and see if we can help solve the problem
and so he did he came over and he he
looked at the problem he looked at my
fridge and he found that it was the
freezer the freezer was collecting water
there was this layer of ice underneath
and every so often I had to just take
kind of a screwdriver and job at it and
then take out the ice and put it in the
sink and the problem would be solved and
and it worked and and kind of been doing
that maybe once a month fixing the the
freezer so that no new ice comes in and
what just blew me away was marks
willingness to come out and help and be
a resource you know wasn't getting paid
for it made almost no commission off of
this rental place for the you know one
month commission that they get but he
cared and he took the time to come out
and went way above and beyond and so
that's why I'm making this video but
mark and that's why when I'm ready to go
get a new place or get a new office
whatever it is mark Singh to the first
guy call so when somebody asking for a
referral I'm gonna pass them on to mark
and so that's how you stand out you know
actually caring about your customers and
going above and beyond so mark thank you
so much I really appreciate it I love
not having to what floor anymore so
thank you for your helpfulness and for
those you watching take some time today
to thank somebody who's helped you in
your life or in your business we don't
do it enough you know we don't reach out
and just say thank you it could be a
video it could be an email it could be a
handwritten note doesn't have to cost
you anything just reach out and say
thank you you'll feel better they'll
feel better everybody wins believe those
are watching you like the video you can
subscribe to the channel watch more
videos just like this thank you so much
I'll see you soon
you